okay good it is a lot of words but I
hope you're getting the sense that like
this is what this is what this is about
this is about interpreting things
knowing that obviously there are numbers
involved but how do I put them together
and make sense of them we don't involve
we've different pair of logic yeah don't
worry it's not hard it's just three
things in common expenses and the
difference so let's do this okay read it
for a second while I drop off this board
just wrap your head around Karen in the
situation that she's um this is one
example before they exercise my dear
it's um prolly no money remember what
haha I don't mean to be rude I know what
you think it's really expensive playing
for some like boarding good point too
many that's electricity what up it
includes stuff like you know home
internet it includes all your community
all I kind of thing she know she buys
before threesome with me carry more I
know you guys so much how many of you
plan to move out from your parents like
at your first like as soon as you can
like mine is yours yeah she's over your
heads when my when I was in unity so
they nice plan to move out but as soon
as I can 18 my dad was like okay you've
got an income like you're a responsible
at all you're going to pay for it it's
not going to be nearly as much as rent
like actually paying for a property can
you want to contribute are you been
freeloading for the last 17 years of
your life art it's time to be activated
contribution and it works very expensive
ok ok I know I've got through so let's
have a look at this we're being asked
for three things let's just not get
overwhelmed let's take it one step at a
time let's first workout her budget
and like I said three pieces right
income expenses and the difference
between them so here's what that's going
to look like her pink have a look how
many sources be home does she have one
too just the one she just has a job and
a weekly take-home pay is 480 awesome
net that's kind of nice so therefore I
try to prepare not just a budget but an
annual budget so I want her and income
that make sense so I'm going to say
income is that boy hundred a dollars and
how do we find out here usually too so
weight of my year we're going to operate
on 52 this is because actually initially
20 4960 okay so that's what we've got to
work with and now we're at the task of
trying to work out well is what's going
out on you like i should do this in
johnson came apart or Jennings where
we're trying to make sure what do we say
what are our two errors of me to avoid
the budget will features for ever
spending overspending and
so making sure we're maximizing your
cell it'll never happen right right good
all right so we know we know how much is
coming in right and that's it we don't
have anything about her youth allows
thankfully she's not old enough to get a
pension etc now we already get to the
next year what was Arthur income
expensive ok so to begin with me right
now rather than just say expenses how
look over her home list right now
importantly they're already lovelies but
i want you to notice they're all kind of
different rates can you see some things
are weekly some things are less
frequently than that right have a look
there's all these different things can
we keep them all in mind how many things
are weekly how make you see why do i get
straight to the table yeah that's fine
that's all right and today is 120 per
week what else you got ok we already
said we've real horrified at how much
she was paperboard you know what it's
not that bad yeah I don't get to the
clothing budget sir
where i knows what's this about what's
this one up that's a sign he's got a
transport yeah every day yeah you know
what I think this me backwards me I'd
spend way more than 35 dolla plan hey
have I missed any weekly expenses khlo
money right at night so what I say is
rather expensive I'm going to gather all
the weekly ones together so I'm going to
say a weekly expenses okay the reason
this is useful it's being over there 52
weeks in a year so i can do all of these
in one here I don't need to consider
this for things because as you can see
by the amount right there is you this is
going to take us quite a while to make
sure we're comprehensive and dealing
with all the official question okay so
weak the extensiveness 52 weeks and
every year weekly expenses that but I
need all of these every single week or
four of these things are happening yeah
so I'm just going to go through one
since time I'm going to go 110 4935 they
still add 120 are you okay Matt back now
will just point out you don't have to
gather it in this way if you have a look
at the textbook way this question
appears it does 52 times this and their
beauty to touch this for the two time
that does it four times one for every
one of their classes easier why not use
295 / 2 I love your phone okay yeah yeah
um I'll tell you why in a second what I
would encourage you to do though is the
issues come up when you've got like when
you've got months and fortnight's and
weeks interacting when you start to
interchange between them they started
affordances like this example is most
months we would say have four weeks but
of course they don't really do that in
fact there's only really
it actually has four weeks so against it
gets very confusing that's why I'm going
to 52 times these and we get to Fort
Madison who soon just some whatever know
about yet sixteen thousand six six
hundred that's all more money right but
then again like living is expensive
right and we haven't even got the same
all right so yes you're right that's all
I and share okay now love God is let's
keep going what does it entertainment is
that like going after its mom just every
three bored I think it's intended to you
by five yeah this is true it's like
what's my youtube build / o 95 dollars
per fortnight these are the fortnightly
expenses right and there are 52 recent
years so that means there are 20 26 for
me you me they used to have limits but
not like this like you know a 10 hour
version of year can play around
somewhere yeah well it's just it's in my
head you have to trucking so data and so
funny videos on okay I was I saying my
five dollars right 26 what nights so 26
months off 95 so we've got another to
employ them do you make money
470 maybe you'll sort of no don't spy
whether or not what must be admitted
surprisingly good writer we've got
monthly expenses I went in at 12 months
in a year she's spending 3 30 a month on
her clothes that gives us what's that
four thousand three down three houses
okay well let's find out how much it
actually ends up with so I've done I
forum I've gotta pay for expenses what's
left is in France is it if it's so I'm
just gonna say different duties so I
start with my income and then I'm going
to have to subtract every single one of
these fossils so i'm going to subtract
this and this
and this okay can get to the whole
advancing now I think I already have
this number so let me get mine event you
guys can concur me whether you agree
yeah happy with that okay now let me
just make a out a quick note once a
difference right that's just this no one
but you can see if she was in the
overspending situation that this number
what would happen to this number you
should enjoy it will be negative exactly
ran if this is negative we call it a
deficit that look you don't have enough
coming in or going out if it's positive
like it is right now to another card
generally we got a surplus ok so it's I
only limited or surplus depending on
whether this is positive money so this
looks all right at the moment